so i'm here with Dylan Dylan what do you
do here at Khan Academy I'm a software
engineer at Khan Academy and right now
I'm working on our free s80 prep that's
rolling out next month and what does
that involve what does that involve the
software engineering cider yeah or all
of the above okay so from your from your
point of view from my point of view so
as a software engineer my job is to
write the code that runs on the Khan
Academy website I'm on the
infrastructure team which means I work
on more of our back-end server code but
I touch all kinds of things and and I've
been working on this essay T project
since about August it was back in server
code do so if you're talking about our
website you have the server code which
which runs in the cloud somewhere and
that that stores all of our user data
and and and and that's where all the
data goes and then the client side is
the front end and that's the code the
java script that runs in your browser or
that's the code that runs on your mobile
devices and this what is this cloud that
people talk about this cloud thing no
one really knows it's a it's not every
water Lee where water vapor was that
valuable yeah yeah yeah I think there's
no water vapor involved water cooling
maybe for the servers a bunch of servers
where the software's running right yeah
so we upload our code there and it runs
and and delivers data and videos and all
kinds of stuff to users and how does
that translate to you on a day-to-day
basis like what is your day like what's
my day like so my day mostly involves on
a good day it's mostly coding a lot of
code reviews review each other's code
and make sure that what we're putting
out is going to work right and be fast
and secure and stable and and respect
users privacy and all that and and I get
to be involved in a lot of the day to
discussions about what the product is
going to be like and what's coming up on
the horizon in terms of new features and
things like that as well as just fixing
the problems that never in evitable e
come up so you've been some of your time
like directly writing code yes doing
direct and a lot of some of your time
working with other team members yeah
yeah so I would say I mean I guess I
should I should my job is to write code
so I to focus on that as much as
possible but in the course of that
there's a lot of collaboration that has
to happen
and just talk about the other engineers
designers data scientists product
managers we have a great great small
group on the s80 team who we worked
together really well and and I'm in
close collaboration with them all the
time yeah and what were you doing before
Khan Academy before Khan Academy I was
an intern at Khan Academy and before
that I was a student at UCLA and had
done various kind of research projects
and was research research research
assistant there and was a computer
science major and how did you stumble on
this path how did you end up here and so
I'd heard of Khan Academy and and didn't
really didn't really think of it as a
place that I might end up working but
knew of it but then I saw a post by
early developer been Caymans on Hacker
News asking if anyone was interested and
kind of describing some of the things
that go on on the technical side at Khan
Academy and that piqued my interest
because I I was i love the technical
stuff but wanted to do something that
would help alot of people as well and so
so it seemed like a great fit and this
one from there had a great internship
and luckily you guys wanted me back to
you and worked out luckily you were
willing to continue to work with us yeah
yeah it was it was mutual I think yeah
and what's what's it been like what's
been surprising about since joining so
one thing that has been really
interesting is just watching it grow and
by it I mean kind of like our team and
our organization as well as our user
base and and our product itself like all
of that has been quite challenging but
super rewarding and and a great learning
experience for for me personally too and
I mean that that kind of it actually is
another interesting question you know
out Silicon Valley's booming right now
and what what made you want to work here
versus you know kind of a traditional
tech company yeah yeah so I think before
I started here I definitely thought that
I was going to work at a traditional
tech company and probably would have
been very satisfied by that probably
would have enjoyed it learned a lot
gotten to do work on interesting
problems but but one thing that I really
like about working here and one thing
that I have now from working here that I
didn't expect to have in my career as a
software engineer
is a the ability to work on something
that is so directly impactful to people
can't get can't get much more direct
than education in terms of helping
people improve their own lives and then
also I I knew this going in but now they
know very well that there are a lot of
hard problems surrounding education and
and they're they're not some of them are
purely technical and those are really
interesting but there are also a lot of
really interesting problems that are
kind of at the intersection of
Technology and people and learning and
teaching and now all of that makes for
some really tough problems but but
really fun ones to talk about on a
day-to-day basis and what advice would
you give to someone else let's say
someone in middle school or high school
who aspires to be you okay um aspires to
be me well there that you might have
gone wrong there already a bad judgment
yeah yeah yeahs valuate your life no I
guess if if you want to be a software
engineer if you want to work at Khan
Academy or just be a software engineer
anywhere or maybe you don't maybe maybe
you are just curious about it there's
there's no excuse for not getting start
as early as you want to there's tons of
stuff out there on Khan Academy and
elsewhere and and tons of people in this
area and and all over the place who
would be would love to share kind of
what it's like and I guess that's my
advice is to to to jump in right away
because the tools are there everything
so much of it is free online able to to
learn all of the things that we use on a
day-to-day basis here to get to get
stuff done on our real site and then the
same type of tools that Google and
Facebook and all those use all that's
free and available so my advice is to
just be really curious and eat up as
much of it as you can and and figure out
if you like it and figure out exactly
what you like and don't like and what
are you most excited about right now
most excited about so like I said we're
working on this essay T project so we're
going to have this s80 mission on Khan
Academy and that's launching in the
first week of june so i'm very excited
about that been working on that since
about August really excited about that
but a lot of other a lot of other stuff
that we're doing is pretty cool too so
excited about everything well thanks for
taking the time out of thanks for being
part of this crazy project thank you